Eh buon pomeriggio a tutti
grazie Il mio è un tema un po'
particolare ma nasce un po'
dall'esigenza mia ma non solo mia
evidentemente da un'esigenza particolare
in un momento così difficile come quello
che stiamo vivendo qualche cosa di per
recuperare quello che siamo noi per
portare verso un futuro migliore tutti
noi tutti Tutta tutte le persone del
mondo la crisi La crisi è stata una
conseguenza di
un'errata sfruttamento della leva
finanziaria
e il fine di questo è un ritorno a breve
del del capitale
ehm del del vivere
dell'oggi guadagno oggi vivo su su su in
questo momento dell'attimo
del
tutto cosa è importante invece è per
ognuno di noi è tornare a
valorizzare per vivere
meglio per riportare tutti i valori che
noi abbiamo dentro di noi e portarli
alla evidenza di tutti e Quest è un po'
Il mio sforzo personale cercare anche
dopo questo questo evento e in
generale far capire a ognuno di noi che
cosa Di che cosa è fatto veramente
essendo io un'imprenditrice ma non solo
essendo madre essendo donna ne sento
fortemente questa questa necessità in un
momento così brutto così particolare in
realtà possiamo trovare invece in noi e
nella società stimoli per per andare
molto meglio per andare avanti per
crescere per essere felici per essere
creativi quello che è che era che è il
fine cioè il bene comune bene mio il
bene della comunità degli altri è
diventato un
mezzo attraverso lo sfruttamento per
certi versi del Lavoro umano del lavoro
delle aziende degli enti e così
via si cca di ottenere il la
remunerazione del del capitale che a
questo punto diventa un fine che è
fondamentale la rimunerazione del
capitale è assolutamente importantissima
ma non è solo questo perché un'azienda
un ente riesca a superare il tempo
Evidentemente c'è bisogno una famiglia
c'è bisogno di portare denaro denaro che
che poi valorizzi il tutto però non è
sufficiente il capitale appunto dà una
temporale e da creazione del del valore
stabile nel tempo ti permette di
sopravvivere Ma è condizione necessaria
non sufficiente Allora che cosa dobbiamo
fare dobbiamo
riportare l'uomo al centro uomo fatto da
una parte fisica dal proprio corpo da
un'anima Noi siamo animati Siamo vivi
come Però anche gli animali sono animati
sono
vivi c'è un'affettività con con i nostri
anim domestici con la natura con con gli
insetti per certi versi perché ci
aiutano con le piante e così
via ma la cosa più importante è tutta la
parte più elevata di noi la spiritualità
quello che ci rende divini per certi
versi Noi siamo figli di Dio e quindi in
quanto tali siamo fatti a immagine
somiglianza di Dio e quindi questa parte
importante della nostra una componente
importante di quello che noi siamo e
quindi tutti noi siamo insieme in questa
sala e nel mondo è importante Mi sembra
di anche con interventi precedenti che
ci sia un filo conduttore fra tutte
queste queste queste queste forze cioè
noi siamo non siamo solo qui noi nella
nostra azienda nella nostra entità nel
nostro mondo del lavoro ma siamo in un
contesto Nazionale europeo mondiale e
siamo nel mondo Cioè nella Terra nel in
un contesto mondiale ecco questa second
Secondo me è una cosa che ognuno di noi
dovrebbe fare propria queste queste
considerazioni è indispensabile quindi
riportare ai veri valori alla
valorizzazione dell'individuo Ma la
valorizzazione dell'individuo quindi di
di di chi sono io e di la gioia di
vivere ci porta alla creatività
allinnovazione la depressione il vivere
alla giornata ci porta ad non essere
nessuno non creare niente e invece
Quante cose belle si possono fare quanto
si può creare
Per che cosa per migliorare la qualità
della vita nostra e di tutto il mondo
delle future generazioni Quindi con una
vista veramente al futuro con le radici
nel passato ma una vista al futuro il
senso della relazione questo è
importante del metterci insieme di
lavorare di cominciare a
fare insieme a creare il nostro futuro
insieme alla comunità creare il nostro
futuro creare uno sviluppo
eh nel nel mondo futuro Questo è
una una base San Benedetto ha Come si
chiama contestualizzato questa regola
oret Labora prega e
lavora e ha cominciato a dire sì prega
pure tu frate tu Monaco Ma pensa che
devi lavorare quindi la preghiera Mentre
mentre lavori
e connota uno stile di vita di preghiera
e riflessione Ma anche diore di lavoro
manuale e intellettuale Quindi io sono
un essere umano lavoro Sono un essere
anche portato verso la preghiera Un
esempio di questo per esempio è il
formaggio Grana che nacque Questo è un
aneddoto che potrà interessare nacque
nella P nella Pianura Padana nel 1135
nell'abbazia di Chiaravalle quindi Anche
questo è un piccolo aneddoto Ecco che
l'esigenza che che nasce è questa
riportare i veri valori la spiritualità
all'interno dell'impresa dell'azienda
dell'entità del dove io lavoro della del
luogo in cui lavoro quindi è la
valorizzazione dell'idea di produttività
della vita spirituale cioè io sono un
individuo produco e la la vita di lavoro
e la vita spirituale insieme
mi portano
a a una vera produttività a verificare
in quanto lo spirito sia una reale
potenza Perché io mi permette di
prendere dentro di me la la forza per
andare avanti e non vi è distinzione fra
lavoro fisico e
spirituale entrambi quindi partecipano
alla produzione dei beni lo spirito è il
principio umano dell'uomo ed è anche il
principio cogente della libertà
dell'uomo Noi siamo uomini liberi e su
questo su questo dobbiamo pensar pensare
moltissimo Siamo liberi perché possiamo
sviluppare noi stessi crescere conoscere
lavorare nella vita sociale Ecco questo
è un punto molto importante si è persa
la focalizzazione delle esigenze degli
uomini del cosa come e quanto produrre
Se pensate per esempio a alcune
coltivazioni Intensive di di tè di di di
riso di quant'altro di grano eccetera
quanto impoveriscono poi la terra mentre
bisogna riportare il tema sul cosa
produrre per chi produrre se serve
quello che sto facendo se serve oggi
perché c'è un'esigenza
già presente già ben chiara oppure
perché io penso che potrà essere nel
breve nel futuro breve un'esigenza per
gli uomini per gli individui nel mondo
come come la devo produrre questa è
anche questo è fondamentale di base e
quanto quanto devo produrre non troppo
non troppo
poco una frase molto che mi ha colpito
di del Papa di Papa Giovanni Paolo I è
il lavoro è per l'uomo non l'omo per il
lavoro come spesso succede dove l'uomo
l'individuo vengono messi non so paesi
come la Cina per esempio vengono messi
come per lavorare per per produrre
per cosa fine a se stessa e poi cosa
succede D di tutte le altre valori
fondamentali spesso e questo è un altro
tema che volevo portare alla vostra
attenzione spesso e purtroppo stiamo
vivendo le persone non hanno voglia di
iniziare una propria personale ricerca
e spirituale o partecipare alla
creazione della
società Ma si affidano a chi assicura
loro nutrimente può essere l'autorità
religiosa lo Stato altri enti non creano
niente vanno a gerla per certi versi se
qualcuno mi dà quello che di cui io ho
bisogno Io mi affido basta questo mi
fino a quando poi non mi manca il cibo
non mi manca il non manca a me alla mia
famiglia e Allora comincio ad agitarmi
ma non è Io direi che forse sarebbe
meglio partire prima quindi dobbiamo
valorizzare e coltivare
correttamente la vita spirituale
produttiva qui ho riportato tre Diciamo
frasi di tre persone diverse qui abbiamo
un padre che dice che lo spirito umano
ha un inizio ma non ha un limite né in
senso temporale né in senso spaziale in
modo simile anche l'attività di impresa
tende a passare le nuove generazioni
come un prodotto dello
spirito la sua attività di ricerca di
idee tende sempre al nuovo e questo è
proprio riportare la spiritualità
all'interno della produttività quindi
dell'impresa un'altra fase che mi
piaceva riportare Questa invece di un
imprenditore un professor Angelo ferro
che dice che nella cultura di impresa i
prodotti sono un atto d'amore sono amore
attivo lo stare con gli altri è un atto
d'amore un'impresa realtà costruita
dagli uomini vive di spiritualità come
matrice
essenziale terzo personaggio è invece Un
economista professor Vitale che dice
Proprio quando si è in crisi quando tu
veramente sei in un momento così
difficile come questo Ecco che comincia
a tirar fuori da te tutta la
valorizzazione tutti i valori che ti
portano a dire c'è bisogno di
spiritualità non solo di un ritorno
economico non solo della macchina della
casa del
del del computer delle cose diciamo
materiali ma di qualche cosa di più
elevato Spirito in termini di spirito di
verità e di amore e questo credo che sia
una considerazione che che troverà tutti
voi che condividerete insomma
ultima frase molto bella molto
importante che vi volevo leggere è
quella di Luigi naudi Nel
1950 che dice migliaia di individui
lavorano producono e risparmiano
Nonostante tutto quello quello che noi
possiamo inventare per molestar
incearca naturale che li spinge non
soltanto la sete di denaro il gusto
l'orgoglio di vedere la propria azienda
prosperare acquistare credito ispirare
fiducia
a clientele sempre più vaste ampliare
gli impianti abbellire le sedi
costituiscono una molla di progresso
altrettanto potente che il guadagno Se
ci pensate quello che ogni giorno noi
viviamo Se così non fosse non si
spiegherebbe come ci siano imprenditori
che nella propria azienda prodigano
tutte le loro energie e inv sono tutti i
loro capitali per ritrarre spesso utili
di gran lunga più Modesti di quelli che
potrebbero sicuramente e comodamente
ottenere con gli altri impieghi Ecco che
riportare alla valorizzazione ai valori
non è sufficiente il guadagno non è
sufficiente una vista breve non è
sufficiente guadagnare tanti soldi
magari in maniera non etica come dice Si
suole dire comunque non maniera
responsabile Perché un termine
importante è ritornare alla
responsabilità al termine della
responsabilità responsabilità delle
persone degli individui responsabilità
dell'azienda responsabilità dei
professionisti Non dimentichiamo che
spesso e volentieri professionisti non
sono responsabili magari fanno anche il
proprio interesse invece questi
professionisti sono coloro che faranno
il bene dell'azienda e infine
nell'impresa c'è proprio questa
necessità di valorizzare Io spero che
Quest mio miei 15 minuti
siano dedicati proprio a questo tema
abbiano portato un piccolo contributo
anche a tutti voi vi
ringrazio